[音楽]
どうもこんにちは次長課長の河本です a
o 0件に行っています
20年ぐらい20年以上たちますかねお笑い芸人やって18から多さが出てきて
もう今年で44歳になりますが
お笑い芸人としていろんなところで活動しておりますそんな僕がですね
今回はお笑い芸人にもかかわらずある
活動を3年くらい前から始めるようになりました
それがですね
こちら sdg ずという言葉でございますが sdd を知っているという方はどれ
位いらっしゃいませんでしょ
あーなるほどありございます
日本の認知度が約15%ぐらいだと言われていますのでまぁあの85%ぐらいの方が
知らないもしくは聞いたことはないとか分からないという方がいても当然なんですが
この sdg ずという私が活動をすることになったきっかけというのがありまして
まあそもそもこの sdg ズってどういう意味なんだろう
とへ
皆さんに江東たところ中にはまああのプロ野球が大好きなんでしょうね
ヤクルト中日巨人って言った人もいますはい
まぁそれぐらいでもいいんでその認知度もいいんですけれどもこの sdg ズって
言うのは持続可能な開発目標ということでまぁ世界中の国連がですね決めた目標です
2030年までに地球をより良い生活できやすいようにしましょうよという目標を掲げ
たと
でまぁこの seg ずというのを私が最初に知る事になるんですけどもまぁその
きっかけというのがですねえぇまぁ色々ありましてこの位置から17のこの目標
これがまあ sdg 頭の中に掲げられているも
不要なんですけど
パッと見た時に
これアフリカのことでしょとか東南アジアストリートチルドレンのことを言ってるんだ
なとか
まあ本当に日本以外のことを言ってるんじゃないかなぐらいな
なので僕はこの s gt ずを知った最初の結果下の時はなんだ僕は世界のために何
か出来ることであるんだろうかみたいな事ぐらいしか考えていませんでした
そうするところ私の会社吉本興業でちょっと sdg ずについて興味がある方は
ちょっとここに来て話聞いてくださいよと言われたので私はここに行きました
で行ってずっと話を聞いていくうちにはもちろん世界中で行われている
貧しい方の話であったりとかいろんなことについて語られてたんですが僕がずーっと
それを考えた時にあれ
これ自分の人生の生い立ちの中に sdg ずの項目と当てはまるのが入ってるん
ちゃうのと
要はこれ世界じゃなくてこれ日本のことについて考えていいんじゃないかっていうこと
に気付かされるわけですよね
でなんでこういう風にしてパッと気づけたかというとやっぱり僕オーライゲーに行って
まして
いろんな所で自分の生い立ちであったりとか本当に苦しかった悲しかった嫌な思い出が
あったというのを全部
笑いに変えていかんとわかるんですよこれがお笑い芸人の職業で
でもそれはやっぱ
明るく楽しくシャベルとお客様を笑ってもらえると
で共感する人もいるんでしょうけどあ
お前がそういうような考えがやったら私もそんなに後ずっと
悲しい思いをしなくて済んだは明るく楽しく生きてられるわという僕は代弁者なので
どんどんどんどん自分の嫌だったこととか恥ずかしかったこととか悲しい事とか言うて
いく職業なんですよね
でそれを言っていったその出来事が吉本興業の僕らの後輩もそうですし同期の子
僕も含めて全部これなかなか sdg 頭の中にパイてるやんと
日本で考えれるやんかっていうようなことに改めて気づかされたので今日はまああの僕
せっかくオーライ原理としてここに立たせてもらってますし
sdg ずの専門家でもなんでもないので僕は自分なりにその僕が経験したことを今日
皆さんの前で喋ってこれは実はこういう項目に当てはまらないですかっ
いうのを皆さんと一緒に考えていきたいなとそういうふうに思うわけでございます
けれども
ハイあの子の17のこの目標がありますがまああの1項目目からね色々校あるんです
私あの
お金が全然なかった時にですねこれあの
まぁ昔の話になりますけど
ファミリーコンピュータというのが入りましてね英一時期ね
ファミコン世代がありまして選んでその中で私はの友達にファミコンを持ってないって
いうことが言えなくてですね
ファミコンを持っているふりをしてドラクエのカセットに並んだことがあるんですね私
全く意味がないんですけど
でずーっとこれ昔ドラッグをやってた人は分かるんですけど深夜から並ばないと朝に
好まギアはないですね長蛇の列ができるのでギリギリまで並んでましたがちょうど抽選
の残りあのお店で10名限定だったんですねその10名の中に深夜に並んだもんだから
入ってましてね
お金もないのにファミコンもないんですよただ友達と一緒に並んでますから
私はずーっと合わせた設定もう残りで俺の番が買い物の番が来るってなった時にお腹
壊したから友達姉に便所に駆け込みまして腹が痛いというので乗り切ったんですよ
そこで私はファミコン持ってないけど持ったふりをずっと続けたんです貧困をなくそう
ですよねこれね
こういうのでやっぱり貧困をなくしていこうと思います私お金ない時にねぇ
なんではからですこれをかねない人のあるあるかもしれないですけど調味料は持ってる
んですよねなぜか
なんでかというと調味料というのは機嫌が結構あるんで1回買ったら1年2年とも積ん
で醤油とマヨネーズがあったんですよ
ただそれにつける食べ物がないだから段ボールを見つけてきて舗装区切りましてねダン
ボールを
でスルメのようにして4
多いとないねーずがあえて食べたんですよね10回20回たて食べてもダンボールです
はずっと
ダンボルずっとダンボール10階にいるが30回ダンボールスマダンボール
50回60回ダンボールです100回超えてくるとね
もう噛んでるのがダンボールが何かもちょっとわからなくなってくるんですよ
ただなんとなく口の中に入れてるんですけど却下い越えたら10回に1回くらいする女
っていうときくるんですよ
これ神田署にしか湧かないただまたダンボールに戻るですまたダンボール頑張るよ
また駄文する女っていうときコムズ品コーナー[ __ ]
飢餓をゼロにこういうところに当てはまりますよね
野性爆弾のクッキー同期なんですようちの相方井上と二人で腹が減りすぎて何故か知ら
ないですけど2人ともヘラ持ってたんですよ
ヘラ大阪の千里一番歩いてましたらあまりにも腹が減ったんでしょう目の前に落ちたら
アスファルトのガムを会等で削って二人とも食べてブルーデリティアてたんですよ
飢餓を02なんですね
私の後輩でとんでもないヤツがいましていっ
親知らずが出来ましたねで親知らずがもう痛くて痛くて親知らずがこう生えてたらいい
んですけどこう生えた状態なんですよ
要は自分の奥歯のところに親知らずがガンガンガンガン当たるから痛いとでも品行なく
そうですけど医者に行くお金がないのでずっと我慢しなんですけど深夜に限界へ来て
激痛
味ってこれはもう無理やと思って自分で糸で縛って
自分でですよ麻酔なしで歯んバーンて抜いたんですよちーアップ動画をダバオと出て
であくる日その家をなんとか止めてかがめてパッと見たら親知らずの1本前抜いてたん
ですよ
質の高い教育をみんないいですよね
なんか痛くなくなりましたというのが奥歯にあたる痛さは衝撃がなくだったんだけど
この子の奥歯を抜いてたんですね
でこういう状態でその3ヶ月ぼ
この痛み全く忘れてこっちまったく同じことをしてんですよ
質の高い教育をみんなですねだからそいつの多くばは今ゼロでなんかしないけどこう
いう歯が生えてるんです
ん奥歯にこんな状態が続いてたりするというようなこともあります
お金がなくてねー短パン一応でぞと冬場しのいでたら
膝が鏡餅みたいになりまして私でおかんにちょっと長ズボンこうてくれとどうしても
長ズボンが必要やってたらベロがるに酔っぱらったオカンが自分のスカート取り出して
真ん中切り出しましてね
で切ったよ両サイドコアラ縫いしましてベルボトムのジーンズで明日から生活で言われ
ましたねこれこれで出た瞬間にねパパ
一方あるといいとか全部パターンで畑まして俺こんな状態で撮って遊んでて
銀行をなくす4結束を
海行きましたねーバーをよ出たらクラゲがもうばんばんばんばんでるんでもうあかーん
でプラ下に刺されたら見たいからもう全員海から上がらやったら全部ビニール袋だった
んですよ
海の豊かが守ろうですよねー
コンビニでう割り箸もらうでしょ割り箸もらったらみんなそれはり場所を1個で使え
ますか
僕らなんかはそれを3分の1にするんですよ3分の1にして
で1/3のあの娘の一個の方は短くまた高細かくハサミでこの最低音爪楊枝として置い
とくんです
残りのにを2日間に分けてやるんですよ
だからも1/3の割り箸ですからこうやって思った時はもうほとんど a で食べて
いるような状態ですよね割り箸と同じ長さになりますので
陸の豊かさを守ろうですよねこれ
後編が金どんどんどんどんあるんですけど八幡働きがいも経済成長もでありますけど私
は吉本興業でですね
あの芸歴1年での時に御堂筋大阪だとわかるんですけど御堂筋て梅田から難波まで全長
4キロあるんですね
全長4キロのところに遠藤がバーッと人が並んでましてそこを御堂筋パレードきてそこ
の御堂筋を
みんなで歩くんですよ
一番最初にもらった職業がですね着ぐるみの中に入ってくれと言われまして池乃めだか
さんの着ぐるみの中に入ってくれ
池乃めだかさん通常だと147センチなんですよネクタイと同じ長さだけど着ぐるみだ
と2メートル30あるんですね
着ぐるみですからでっかく見せなきゃいけないのでで横にいた4巻庄司さんが3年寅八
重あったんです
で僕は2m 32
池乃めだかさんのところに入って御堂筋パレード歩いてくれと炎天下真夏ですよ
真夏ですペットボトルの500のところがありましてここにストローがバーンと長いの
ついてましたここで水分を補給してください
スタートですのでもうここの中がすでにもう50度近くあるんですよ
梅田からずっと歩いて淀屋橋でもこのカラーになりましてこのペットボトルが500が
あった
いう間に底からあと3キロぐらいあるんですよ全力疾走でもう沿道に手を振る今なんか
ないですとにかくゴールめがけなると口の中でずっと死ぬ死ぬ死ぬって言いながら
ゾーンと難波まで行ってやっとなってあああやっとこさ着いたと思って社員の方が来て
今日のギャラや腕たこ焼き渡されたんですよ
ギャラじゃないですたこ焼きですよ炎天下
最悪水やと水が欲しいとカラカラになった状態でたこ焼きて
働きがいも経済成長もに入りますねこういうのがねこういうのも全て入ってくるわけ
ですよね
a
後も色々あります気候変動には具体的な対策をというもの13番というのはありますね
暑くなったらクーラーつけますか寒くなったら暖房をつけますか
我々はそういうことをしません暑くなったら部屋からとにかくでて日陰を探すんです
とにかくし影を探してぞと練り歩いたことありますお金が回りませんしそういうことで
機構対策
に申し出ますあとこちら6番もございますけれども6番私あのおばあちゃん子でござい
ましておばあちゃんとずっと住んでますと
おばあちゃんというの昔の人ですからすごい大胆なこともするんですけど
ボットン便所ですね昔はボットン便所なんですけどそのポットン便所がずーっとこう
あのなかなか汲み取りの人が来ないと上がってくるんですよ
は言わば下からでしたから上がってくるともうそろそろ見えてきてるんですよ
が見えてきている状態の時は行ったらいけないんですねそれじゃあ行ったらあふれます
ので
近くの小川でしてこう言うてまああの便所の代わりに近くの小川いてずっとこうしてた
んですけどそのから下でずっとおじいちゃん顔笑ってますからね
これはです6番の安全なヘスとトイレを世界中にというふうなことになります
こう見るといろんなことがこの sdg 頭の中に組み込まれてるんですよ
これ厄介だなとこれ全部今
言ったの日本で行われていることやんかというようなことになってきたわけですよ
ただこれ今井皆さんにこうやってあのお話ししてリアクション前あのしてくれるお客
さん宅様
やっぱり大人な方やったらこういうトークでいいでしょうただしこれ2030年と
先ほどどうも申しました通り
あと10今2019ですから11年間もあるわけですよね
そうすると子供たちにも教えていかないとその子供たち12剤だった小学校6年生の子
ばもう社会人1年生になるわけですからその時にどういうふうに考えられるかという
意味で子どもたちにもわかりやすく教え様というようなことで私はこういうお話だけで
はなくてですね実は
こういうふうにへ
吉本の芸人でみんなでタッグを組みまして
座長になりまして私がコントを繰り広げてお送りしてるわけです
この場合ですと海を俺の海をという態度でありますけども
14番の海の豊かさを守ろうというのはこういうようなことなんですよと言いながら
左にくまだまさし君がいたりとかあと
海の女神で椿鬼奴ちゃんが女神で出てくるんですけどもゴミをいっぱいつけていると
あなたたちのせいで海の音がに海が汚れているんですよというのを子供たちにねみんな
に見せてはからしてあげるというような
でこれを20分30分の sdg ずコントとしてお送りしまして
でそのまま
終わりましてあるちっちゃい7歳8歳くらいの男の子がですねこれから海に行ったとき
にもうゴミ捨てませんで僕に言ってくれたんですこれだけでもかなり成果です
ただし椅子にえーい
ルパンの館勝生置いて帰りましたその子
海は守ったけどもリプは守れなかったというしかしそういうことでもいいんです sdg
頭がわかってね海をとにかく守りたいという気持ちが出てきただけでも十分なんです
次の翌年には海ではなくテーマは特殊能力小学校と書いてますけれども se ず4番
目にあります
質の高い教育をみんな木ということで今度はこの高い教育をみんなに受けていただくに
はどうしたらいいかっていうのを
特殊能力の小学校で
まあ我々がコントを繰り広げてっていうのをやってたんですけどまぁ一番映えに行く
まだまずは主君がいいますけども
練習の時からですねくまだまさし君が特技がありましてその特技というのは口に
クラッカーを超えまして口の蔵顔パーンって引いたらお尻から蔵家がバーンて出ると
言うと
ブッシュ走力を食っているというそういう芸というか早くなんですよ
でそれはずっとわかってたんですけども熊田ませさんはこれをやって皆さんのお客さん
の反応を見るのが大好きな人ですからその後のことを全く考えてなくてですねその後
この方は20分間座らなきゃいけないんです
なのでここにぷらっ母がついたままずっとこの体勢でです
ほんとをやってて非常に滑稽だったらどっちクラッカーがここから前方
この状態でずっとそうじゃなきゃいけないというくまだまさし君がいたりそういうよう
なことでみんなで盛り上がって seg ずを広めていこうではないかという
でこれをやってたわけですねそうするとまぁ子供たちが最初に食いついてくれて食卓
囲んだ時にお父さんが
山 sdd ずの質の高い教育についてみんなで話し合いができるのではないかという
ようなことでございますね
はい
こちらは sdg ずマルバツクイズこれは参加型になりまして今日のようなお客さん
に質問をいたしまして問題だしてマルかバツかに分かれて
で
一番最後まで残った方には景品プレゼントみたいなことがありました
このマルバツクイズにも地球はね衛星から見たらすごく多く見えるかもしれませんけど
も
じゃあその青く見えるようなこれは全部飲んでる水なんか出たらそうじゃないですよね
海水だったりするので
この地球規模から考えて飲める水というのがコップ1杯
の水であるマルかバツかというような問題でまぁ正解は罰で立った
スプーン小さじ1杯分ぐらいしかないんです人間が飲めるお水というのはそれぐらいの
比率なんですよ
なのでまぁ顔を洗うときに水が出版にその屋根ようなとかそういうことは子供に入れる
わけですよね
こういうマルバツクイズでもみんなで楽しみながらお送りすることができるというよう
なことでございます
でこちらは sdd ずの作文と言いましてある企業がですね
sdg ズンズンと学びたいんですけど企業というの大きい会社で出来ていますので
部署ごとに行ったら初対面の方もいらっしゃるんです
コミュニケーションを取らなきゃいけないですよねとなったときにじゃあ sdg 頭
を使ってあいうえお作文を作っていきましょうというようなことで
sdgs このねちっちゃい s を使ってみんなでこうああいう7作るとそういう
するとこう
コミュニケーションでいろいろな話題が出たり
ここを s をどうしましょうかねぇとか a
散々とかっていうふうにしまり屋やしんどい
だんだんガンガンとかというでみんなでこう話し合って自分5校
盛り上げてでーすジーズの作物くるこれは非常にあのチームの色が出るといいますが
そのチームのリーダーのことを述べたりとかっていうようなことも皆さんでやってた
非常に楽しめたで何がいいかというと結局 sdg ズっていう言葉を覚えて帰れます
ので
うんこの言葉を覚えて帰るというだけでも認知度は15%で言いましたけどそれが
上がるだけでも十分なことでございますので私としては非常に良い成果が出たんじゃ
ないかなと思っております
ザーというわけで
私のこの sdg ずというのは私なりに広めていきたいと思いますけれども
今日言える簡単なことでございますが地球はとにかく病気をしているわけですよ
地球が病気をしているで一人一人がお医者さんになれるんです今日今日からお医者さん
になれる
で sdg ずというのは総合病院だと思っていただいて結構です
で総合病院の中に
17の科目があると普通の病院だったらで外科ではないかた整形外科た系政権がた農経
方ってありますけど自分だったらこの他の専門の医者になれますよというのを皆さんで
17このうち見つけていただけたらいいんですそしたらお医者さんになれるんですから
地球を守るお医者さんになっていただきたいんですよだから本当の病院
の先生を見つけて仮にもその先生が居酒屋で食い散らかしてタバコポイ捨てしてゴミつ
でて水だしっぱなしにしてたら皆さんはそのお医者さんにこう言ってあげてください
お前は人は守れても地球は直されへんに野党
どうもあれだした車
[拍手]